bonjour à tous les invités le choc a dit
ce matin louis boutrin bonjour bonjour
vous êtes conseiller exécutif et vice
président de martinique transport mais
vous avez été le lance l'un des lanceurs
d'alert sur le chlordécone avec raphaël
confiant
justement depuis lundi se déroule la
commission d' enquête parlementaire
quel regard jetez vous sur cette
commission monsieur livory je demande
aux auditeurs de nous écouter parce
qu'ils très grave
cette commission enquête parlementaire
est une commission d enquête
parlementaire tronquée pour moi c'est
une honte pour la martinique où quoi
vous dites ça vous savez depuis 2002
personnellement j'étais le rédacteur
d'une proposition de résolution pour une
commission d'enquêté parlementaire
porté par le député pierre sambou nous
n'avons jamais jamais mais je le dis
depuis 2002 jamais entendu l'actuelle
députée siège letchimy sous ces
questions le chlordécone pire et je dis
que c'est une honte puisque on le sait
au mépris de tout principe de précaution
monsieur letchimy qui était alors
président de la région martinique de
2010 à 2015 avait lui même demandé une
dérogation pour l'utilisation et la
prorogation de l'épandage aérien alors
qu'un directives européennes qui
détiennent
c'est d'autant plus honteux que comme
vous le savez le choix dix invités pour
cette commission parlementaire ous avez
bien compris que chaque journaliste
chaque reporter comme yann arthus
bertrand qui a fait un film sur cette
question quand ils viennent en
martinique
il vient avec notre livre qui est sorti
en 2007 on parlait pas encore de
lanceurs d'alert mais nous avons publié
un livre pour révéler au grand jour ce
scandale du chlordécone lors de la 2 au
delà du serge letchimy est ce qu'on ne
peut pas avoir un consensus martiniquais
autour de cette question est est ce que
vous pouvez pas faire fi de vos
divergences pour le bien commun
il s'agit pas de divergence nous avons
lancé des appels nous avons sillonné la
martinique raphaël confiant et moi pour
pouvoir sensibiliser les martiniquais et
appelé les élus sens à l'assemblée
nationale en 2007
qu'en martinique mais ce code pin tung
aux autres ses symboles et du haut
escaut dr ping pong aux autres et faire
baghai pour ne faisons pas du hors sujet
monsieur livory parlons du sujet du jour
le sujet du jour c'est que nous avons
une commission d enquête parlementaire
et nous assistons à une violation du
principe à valeur constitutionnelle qui
est celui de la séparation des pouvoirs
entre d'une part le pouvoir législatif
et l'autorité judiciaire et ça depuis
2007 puisque le député lurel le député
marie jeanne ont déjà demandé ces
commissions d'enquêté parlementaires
pourquoi as tu sont accordés aujourd'hui
cette commission enquête parlementaire
parce que effectivement dans quand vous
regardez la lettre de mission et la
lettre qui a été adressée par la garde
des sceaux et qui fait partie des
annexes du rapport du député letchimy
vous constatez que il est demandé que le
périmés de la commission n'a peut-être
pas l'inventaire envisagée est
susceptible de recouvrir pour partie
celui une information judiciaire en
cours et que dès lors la ministre y
garde des sceaux attire l'attention sur
l'articulation entre la tête par le
monde y est la procédure judiciaire qui
est actuel ce qui veut dire que monsieur
ennjimi ne peut pas entendre les parties
civiles à cette affaire
il ne peut pas entendre les
latifundistes qui se sont constituées
parties civiles
dès lors on ne peut pas prétendre comme
il le fait dire qu'il veut identifier
les responsabilités des autorités et des
acteurs publics dans la prolongation de
l'autorisation quand même pas inutile
elle est inutile on y apprend des choses
on y apprend quoi on y apprend ce qu'on
sait déjà
yb et en plus on assiste à une mise en
scène médiatique que nous sommes obligés
aujourd'hui de dénoncer c'est une mise
en scène médiatique
nous n'apprenons rien de plus de ce que
nous savons les archives jal qui
existent bel et bien sûr on le sait vous
oubliez monsieur niveau et j'ai eu une
obligation effectivement de réserves sur
cette question puisque je suis l'avocat
d'une des parties civiles et notre
planète a été dit paul harris et au pôle
santé du tj de paris
pour l'autre nous disons que devant la
gravité de la situation devant le fait
que nous avons aujourd'hui un drame
humain et des conséquences eux sans
précédent on ne peut pas accepter cette
tentative de récupération médiatique et
politique parce que il n'en sortira rien
dès lors que vous ne pouvez pas entendre
ceux qui sont responsables et qu'ils ont
été identifiés sur dans cette affaire
vous ne pourrez pas établir les
responsabilités et il est impératif que
l'on puisse établir les responsabilités
si on veut de maintien parlé de
réparations fil des mutations des
victimes
voilà là on en est alors je ne vais pas
participer et vous pensez bien que j'ai
une obligation morale aujourd'hui
d'alerter la population à nouveau pour
dire qu'une mascarade qui se déroulent
aujourd'hui et que nous ne pouvons pas
être resté silencieux face à cette
mascarade alors nous poursuivons vous
est aussi vice-président de ceux ci et
non ceux ci étant ceci étant il y à un
certain nombre de choses à faire
le président ma proie entrouvert la
porte avec son discours du trône rouge
où il a déjà reconnu qu'effectivement la
responsabilité de l'état à nous d'ouvrir
complètement et totalement cette porte
parce que nous devons demander
effectivement l état et le député
letchimy peut tout à fait le faire
demander à ce qu'on ne puisse ouvrir les
comptes de la sécu également de la caf
de manière à ce qu'on puisse avoir et
des différents registres des planteurs
de bananes que l'on puisse savoir quels
sont les ouvriers agricoles qui de 72 à
2002 ont travaillé dans la banane
quelles sont ces ouvriers s qui sont
toujours en vie et quel est leur état de
santé
faire un recensement de tous les
ouvriers agricoles qui ont travaillé à
cette époque
hélas nous n'avons pas encore obtenu si
régis lui il peut l'obtenir
et en plus quand je parle de mascarade
vous avez bien vu l'interrogation
l'audition pardon du député lordinot
c'est quoi cela de côté
il est sous serment et il pouvait
effectivement quand il dit qu il y a eu
de la banane dans les années 2000 ce qui
nous fait dire que le scandale a
continué jusqu'en 2002
au lieu de nous demander quelles sont
ses preuves et d'apporter des éléments
de preuve monsieur letchimy reste muet
et c'est votre consoeur c'est votre
consoeur cécile mah qui lui pose la
question après c'est vrai qu'après il
n'est plus sous serment est là toute
latitude pour avant un large sourire et
pour dire rien avoir à l'oeil alors je
vous pose d'autres questions va pas il à
vous est venu aux autres coprésidents de
marché transport il faut qu'on parle de
ma part j'ai quand même je me connais je
mène les débats quand même surréaliste
de voir un devoir comme chez ernoul soit
assis et nous dire qu'il n'a pas de
responsabilité et que c'est l'état qui
est responsable
l'état a commencé à reconnaître sa
responsabilité il est temps que les
latifundia reconnaissent leur
responsabilité là dedans
il est temps qu'ils apportent une
contribution efficace à cet agrès cette
enquête pour faire évoluer et ça au nom
des nombreuses victimes et de tous ceux
qui souffre actuellement de cancer de la
prostate en entier je vais finir par
poser la question sur les transports
donc la réforme des lycées a institué
des spécialités dans l'établissement des
dans les établissements pour résumer
faute de transports les élèves
n'arrivent pas à rejoindre leur et 13
bis leur établissement pour suivre les
cours on essaie martinique transport qui
est chargé de faire ce transport entre
les différents lycées que ce facile
pourquoi quel est le problème le
problème est simple depuis juillet juin
2019 et vous avez cette lettre du
président alfred marie jeanne qui est
président du conseil d'administration du
marching transports il écrit au recteur
et le président dit à au recteur contenu
de cette réforme des lycées de nous
donner toutes les informations pour que
l'on puisse organiser le service contenu
là la réforme des lycées
madame sa soutane qui est par ailleurs
conseiller exécutif en charge de
l'éducation a elle-même interpellé à
deux reprises d'abord en janvier 2019 et
ensuite le 18 juin 2019 sur les
conséquences de cette réforme selon
l'organisation que nous nous ré à m
envoyer la balle nourriture est ce qu'on
ne me sens pas est-ce qu'on peut
contraindre à se rendre
val et de cappone parfois ses
responsabilités oui nous prenons une
responsabilité mais il faut d'abord
établir les faits nous ne pouvons pas
accepter des accusations dès lors que ça
ne relève pas effectivement de notre de
nous nous avons vous dites aujourd'hui
aux parents est ce que demain ou bien la
semaine prochaine il y aura un service
pour permettre aux élèves de rejoindre
leur établissement
nous avons opté pour la facilité mais
nous sommes en responsabilité et nous
avons demandé au recteur de point ses
responsabilités de nous informer
sans ces informations ne peut pas mettre
le transport à disposition des des
lycéens au jeu vous à veut dire qu'il
n'y aura pas de transport jusqu'à la
révérence a été tardive et malgré que
cette réponse est tardive nous sommes
dans une démarche très constructive nous
allons faire en sorte que nous puissions
transporter les différents lycées lien
vers l'hiver des établissements où
effectivement ils doivent suivre des
cours yves ça va nous demander
effectivement des modifications des
marchés scolaires
ce n'est pas une et des avenants aux
conventions et aux délégations de
service public qui ont déjà été passés
donc vous comprenez que ce n'est pas par
un craquement droit que l'on le fait que
et que aujourd'hui nous sommes dans une
difficulté à la fois également technique
mais nous avons déjà rencontré les
transporteurs et techniquement nous
allons apporter des réponses pour
effectivement voir ça ce prix mais ça je
viens de vous le dire est que je vous le
dit quand je vous le dis vous me dites
vous vous me renvoyez à la même phrase
on ne peut pas assister à un renvoi de
balle
nous prenons nos responsabilités nous
n'avions pas les éléments nécessaires
pour nous permettre de mettre à
disposition de ses 102 lycéens sur les
20000 qui sont abonnés aux transports
scolaires nous n'avions pas la
possibilité de le faire maintenant que
nous avons les différents éléments
nous allons pouvoir mettre en place des
bus de 22 places au pouvoir assurer les
trajets de sega ça pose un problème
d'assurance également puisque ces gamins
qui sont problèmes qui sont transportés
ne sont pas tous inscrits au transport
scolaire
donc il va falloir là aussi régularisés
par se joue mal et panis phangan s'il ya
un accident demain nous sommes en
responsabilité et c'est le président du
conseil exécutif qui est pénalement
l'évolution du transport dans le nord
parce qu'il faut aller vite il nous
reste à peine une minute
le transport dans le nord c'est une
révolution
nous allons inviter l'ensemble des
maires du nord en compagnie des deux
coopératives le lundi 23 septembre à la
halle a cité m
pour pouvoir assister à la signature des
deux conventions
nous avons réorganisé le transport avec
une un mot c'est la même qui s'occupe de
la ratp
nous avons également réuni l'ensemble
des transporteurs qui aujourd'hui sont
les salariés les coopératives effectué
déjà le service ont été indemnisées
nombre ont reçu la citation de lévis des
volontaires au départ comme monsieur
nahla moutou qui avait deux lignes entre
saint-pierre et le prêcheur et saint
pierre hémon et rouge qui a fait valoir
ses droits à la retraite
les transporteurs seront indemnisés ils
vont ceux qui ont accès à l'aide aux
dispositifs d aide à cessation
d'activité pourront avoir grâce au
président marie jeanne 80000 euros
puisque avant le dispositif c'était deux
fois quarante mille euros voilà les
apports et ceux qui à d'important à dire
c'est que nous allons ouvrir de
nouvelles lignes puisque inclure une
ligne qui à la saint-pierre à joues pas
l'oreille vers trinité nous allons
également hibou très c'est terminé je
vous remercie le temps est court
je vous remercie bonne journée à
l'écouté de nos programmes choco merci